when my mother had breast cancer she was
only 43 and that was a time when there
was no such thing as chemotherapy for
breast cancer there's no such thing as
hormonal therapy for breast cancer so
it's a very rewarding for me now have so
many things in our armamentarium that we
can do for patients and the other thing
that's very important is you know really
to help people understand you don't have
to feel helpless out there just waiting
you know that you know it's like the
analogy well if the bullets got my name
on it I guess there's nothing I can do
about it it's not like that with cancer
people need to know that just having
some wisdom you can be proactive we take
preventative actions every day in our
life we fasten our seatbelts before we
drive a car to prevent fatal auto
accidents we brush our teeth to prevent
tooth decay you can be taking the same
actions against developing cancer as you
take in every other walk of your life it
doesn't mean that there's a hundred
percent guarantee just like fascinating
your seat belt that you're not going to
die in a fatal auto accident but it
lowers your risk and there are a number
of Risk Reduction strategies that people
can employ is just a little bit of note
hm